so let's examine where we go from here
on border security and immigration
reform we have with us tonight Border
Patrol agent Hector Garza he's the vice
president of the National Border Patrol
Council and Francisco Hernandez who's an
immigration attorney Hector I've been
with you down on the border I appreciate
the great work the men and women do
it's amazing hard and difficult but tell
us what is happening right now on the
border are people able to get across and
what if all of a sudden 1,100 people
showed up in your sector
well what scabbing of the border is that
catch you releases alive and well and
unfortunately a lot of the Obama
holdovers within our agency are still
implementing those same policies that
were in fact under the Obama
administration
unfortunately if these are this Caravan
makes it to the southern border and they
cross the illegal into your country
there will be processed but then they'll
be released on a on a notice to appear
which means that they'll disappear into
the American communities and they'll
never return to port now Francisco what
what is the case what why not build this
wall the video that we were just showing
was video that I took when I was down on
the border you see a wall and then it
stops and it just becomes barbed wire
fence so all right what why not well the
wall what's the best case you got why
not put one on me okay first of all
public officials and law enforcement
officials have to remove politics from
doing their job our sheriff bill way
born in Fort Worth does that right now
the problem is you don't know what a
good thing to do I get it I don't know I
want to know what is your best friends
to tell you well I just want you to
focus on the wall why not build an
actual wall okay look we can't do it but
if you want to work you can't do it you
saw that way do they just have here
tried we tried in 2001 doesn't work we
get deeper tunnels toward ladders the
problem is you got to reforming
immigration laws here the ones that we
have are not working you're right mr.
Border Patrol agent are you telling me
that ice and Border Patrol can't do
their job without the cities and local
governments helping are you saying you
need Mexico to control our borders I
don't think you can say that now mr. no
sighs you have a chance to answer Hector
would a wall help you or not help you
so a wall would definitely help Border
Patrol operations that's all I want to
know Francisco go back explain to me you
just the guy works
he spent decades serving on the border
it's easier better for them to protect
2,000 miles abort of the border with a
wall so why not build it all look look
I'm okay for building well we're gonna
have to legalize 100,000 Mexicans to
build and that's a damn good start the
problem is we tried in 2001 and 2002 and
it fell and we cancelled it because of
budget overruns guys let's get on the
immigration reform but you know what
President Trump is crawfishing because
he doesn't have the votes on his own
side why do we need the Democrats why do
we need the Democrats over afraid
they're filibustering the sky is falling
let them filibuster call the bluff draw
the line in the sand all right let me
answer that question the reason you need
Democrats is because you need 60 votes
in the Senate the old decisions the
authorization to build the wall is there
because because both parties don't know
how to remove the politics from doing
their job just like sheriffs you guys
are all focused on Yosemite Sam in
Arizona chef bill way burns over here
following the law you guys need to get
on the ball Border Patrol doesn't need
help
ice doesn't need help we need the laws
to be changed daca has nothing to do
with all of these folks these are 800
900 sectors you have my calling dreamers
it's a nightmare there they've never
been to any of the country that other
than America and they're talking about a
caribou are we funding them if they
don't give Hector that's what they're
for Hector hold on Hector what's the
reality I went to the Eloi Detention
Facility okay I saw people from a
hundred and fifty different countries
there this isn't a problem about just
Mexico what is the reality of what
you're seeing of people coming across
the border Jason this is nothing more
but a rampant abuse of our immigration
system these people are coming to our
border and making false asylum claims
most of these claims do not stand up to
the judicial overview
and they don't they don't qualify for
asylum claims many of these people in
their countries that they flee their
country because there's gangs and crime
so they train Francisco weakest
tradesmen Cisco with a butcher of a
button don't tell me you can't stop the
trains from coming over here across the
border of course we can we have a button
on the trains
we control Commerce on the trains I hate
to tell you Francisco don't know just a
false narrative here there I've seen it
I've gone out with Hector I've actually
seen this coming across you have no
taste you have no case we're not
building the wall can't do their job I
think you're wrong
Border Patrol is fantastic the troops do
a great job let them do their job and
remove the politics from letting them do
their job here's a union guys we're in
at all ages you're an attorney you get
this you understand this I get this help
me here when somebody crosses the border
they don't run I was shocked when I went
down there they don't run what they do
is they claim this island
Hector then what happens what we're
asking for is free wine strategic
locations that's gonna save American
lives but not only American lives but
it's gonna keep our agents from getting
assaulted on a daily basis and not only
that these people that are coming across
they're falling prey to the cartel a lot
of these people are being a put into
slave labor sex labor you name it
they're being they're all in the greater
you are the leader of the Border Patrol
Union less than 20% of the Border Patrol
agents book belong to your union you do
not speak for Border Patrol
I know both patrolling is a Border
Patrol agent by saying they can't do
their job Francisco Francisco and Hector
listen I thank you both it is a lively
debate there's a lot more to discuss on
this but I got to tell you I think the
reason the Democrats are fighting so
hard against the border wall is that it
works and they want they want people
coming here and if you claim it silently
all that if you come here and you claim
asylum then you're going to be assigned
to a judge and it's going to
take you five six years before that case
is adjudicated yes it will that's why I
have to crazy it is we'll talk some more
about this gentlemen thank you for being
here we've got to move on